Speaker 1: The other thing that there is shame
to be talked about is on federal prosecutors.
I have been talking on my own channel for
years now about consequence for Donald Trump
in the wake of the attempted overthrow of the
United States government. The insurrection,
the failed coup attempt. By way of
overturning a free and fair election.
They could prosecute, that they could have
prosecuted obstruction of justice, the multiple
cases of obstruction of justice outlined in the
Mueller report. They didn't. And in this case,
they could have prosecuted the hush money
payments made to Stormy Daniels. But instead,
prosecutors and I'm going to read a little bit
from this. Instead, prosecutors thought, oh, this.
This will seem small in comparison to all of the
insane treason and other crimes of Donald Trump.
We're just not going to bring this. And this is a
problem. Justice should be met. Justice should be
served no matter if you think it's a small matter
and something or something else will come along.
Can't pass the buck to someone else when
you have a prosecutable crime before you.
Reading from the CNN article, Federal prosecutors
discuss charging Trump in Stormy Daniels case when
he left office. Book says Days before then,
President Donald Trump left the White House.
Federal prosecutors in New York discussed whether
to potentially charge Trump with campaign finance
crimes once he was out of office, according to a
new book from senior CNN legal analyst Elie Honig.
Prosecutors from the Southern District of New York
developed significant evidence against Trump when
they charged his former attorney, Michael Cohen,
in 2018 over a hush money scheme paid to women
claiming affairs with Trump, including adult
film star Stormy Daniels, Honig writes. But
prosecutors did not consider charging Trump
at the time because of longstanding Justice
Department guidance that a sitting president
cannot be indicted. I hope you caught that.
I hope you caught that one line in there that
they developed significant evidence against Trump
when they charged his former attorney and then
eventually had a conviction for Michael Cohen.
They had evidence and they chose not to prosecute.
This is this is a failure of the United
States Justice Department. This is a
failure of justice in general. It should
be dispassionate. He committed a crime.
You convict. You investigate, you prosecute, and
you secure a conviction. I understand that the
Office of Legal Counsel within the Department
of Justice has a long standing memo. This
isn't the law. This is an opinion within a
division of the Department of Justice that
says you can't charge a sitting president. That is
nonsense. And many experts agree. Continuing with
the article here with Trump about to leave office
in January 2021, however, Audrey Strauss, the
acting U.S. attorney, held multiple discussions
with a small group of prosecutors to discuss its
evidence against Trump. They decided to not seek
an indictment of Trump for several reasons, Hoenig
writes, including the political ramifications
and the fact that Trump's other scandals,
such as such as efforts to overturn the 2020
presidential election and the January six, 2021
insurrection made the campaign finance violations
seem somehow trivial and outdated by comparison.
What the crime was committed, was it not? You
secured a conviction with someone involved
with the crime. Why would you let Donald Trump
off the hook? It. Is it laziness? What is it?
It's malpractice as far as I'm concerned.
Continuing here, quote, We were well aware of
the prudential reasons why you wouldn't charge
the president even after he was out of office.
While federal prosecutors in New York opted
not to pursue their case against Donald Trump,
Manhattan District Attorney Alvin Bragg appears
to be looking into the matter again. Cohen met
this month with prosecutors from his office,
the first such meeting in more than a year,
and the clearest sign to date that the
Manhattan district attorney is gearing
in on the Trump Organization's involvement
in the House money payments. So look, look.
I have said this going back in the days after
the insurrection, that we are going to have to
rely upon journalists and people writing books
for the investigatory work to be done because
federal prosecutors, they're not up to it, in
my estimation. Merrick Garland has sat on his
hands. Well under the guise of, well, we want
to be thorough and slow paced in our in our
investigation, that we want to do this the right
way. And sober minded. We don't need to drag our
feet until Joe Biden isn't president anymore. And
then the entire thing is scuttled. And here we
have further evidence that they just decided not
to prosecute because, oh, there's bigger things.
Republicans right now want to talk about a two
tiered justice system in the United States. Joe
Biden's not being treated the same way as
Donald Trump about the documents. None of
that is true. But that's not what two tiered
is. They're both presidents. That's one tier.
It's that if I committed the same crimes
as Donald Trump, I'd be sitting my ass in
a prison right now. But because he's rich,
because he's an ex-president, because he
has powerful connections, he gets a pass. And
federal prosecutors gave him that pass. It's all
too much. I'd love to know what you think.
Let's mix it up in the comments and follow
me. You can subscribe to our YouTube
channel, Jessy Dallimore, or follow me on
Twitter Instagram. Tik Tok Dallimore. I'd love to
see you back. Thanks a lot for joining me today